Just a heads up, we’re gonna talk about
contrails today and I’m going to say the
word moist.
A lot.
Moist Hey there everyone, Julian in for DNews.
Every now and then you’ll look up and see
thin white clouds streaking across the sky.
As most of you know those come from airplanes,
but you may be wondering how they form, or
what they’re made of.
Now, some might have you think that contrails
are chemicals dumped into the air by the government
to control your mind and make you download
Pokemon Go.
But as it turns out they’re just Ice.
Ice baby.
For the most part.
See, ice crystals form more easily when water
vapor has a seed it can latch onto and start
crystallizing.
If you’ve ever done that fun experiment
at home where you cool distilled water past
0 degrees celsius and then dunk an ice cube
in to instantly freeze the whole thing, you
might know what I’m talking about.
Aircraft exhaust consists of CO2, water vapor,
nitrous oxides, carbon monoxide, sulfates,
hydrocarbons, soot and metal flakes.
Some of those aerosols are just the “ice
cube” needed for larger ice crystals to
grow.
Actually aircraft exhaust provides more than
just the starting point for water vapor in
the air to condensate, it actually adds more
water vapor.
Jet fuel, like the gasoline in your car, is
made up predominantly of hydrocarbons.
Hydrocarbons, as the name implies, are molecules
of hydrogen and carbon.
When they’re mixed with oxygen and combusted,
the chemical products are carbon dioxide and
H2O.
You know that water dropping out of your muffler?
Same concept.
So exploding jet fuel contributes more water
to the air, upping the moisture past its saturation
point and kicking off the ice forming process.
At least that’s how it happens when the
ambient air is already moist and cold enough.
If it’s too dry or warm, you get no contrails
at all.
The moisture also determines how long the
contrails stick around for.
As the exhaust cools, if it’s just barely
in the moisture threshold, contrails will
form and then disappear after a few minutes.
If the ambient air was more moist to begin
with, they’ll persist, sometimes even spreading
out as a sheet with the wind.
You may have seen contrail cousins like the
wisps left by wingtips.
Obviously those aren’t caused by jet exhaust,
but they are caused by a drop in pressure.
At high angles of attack like during takeoff
or during high g-maneuvers, the wingtip boundary
stirs up a vortex, and the vortex drops the
pressure.
When pressure drops, temperature drops, so
even though the moisture level hasn’t changed,
the air is now cold enough to become liquid
water, albeit briefly.
Now I know, I can practically hear some of
the comments already, claiming that contrails
are one big fat conspiracy and I’m a shill
or a sheeple… sheeperson?
What’s the singular form of sheeple?
But evidence would suggest otherwise.
There are actual airplanes that intentionally
dump out chemicals, like crop dusters or aerial
acrobatic teams like the RAF’s Red Arrows
that use smoke effects.
The Red Arrows actually make smoke by dumping
diesel directly into the exhaust, so it sounds
pretty similar to how chemtrails are purported
to work.
But these mists or plumes of smoke can be
seen directly behind the nozzles or engine.
Since contrails are formed by freezing water,
there’s a gap between the engine and the
trail.
At 8 kilometers up it is mighty cold, less
than -40 degrees celsius, but it still takes
some time to cool the hot exhaust gasses to
freezing.
Hence the gap.
Hence the evidence that it’s just ice.
Much as I like thinking about conspiracies
they’re almost never true…
almost [wink].
Yet people still believe them.
To find out why, I explored it in another
video over here.
Seriously what is the singular form of sheeple?